COMING UP NEXT.
>>> BUT LET ME LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS.
HOW SLOW CAN YOU GO WHEN IT
COMES TO A POLICE CHASE YOU A?
GOOD QUESTION.
A CROWD MESMERIZED TWO HOURS.
THIS SUSPECTED DRUG DEALER,
YOU'LL SEE A WHITE CAR ROLLING
DOWN THE HIGHWAY, AT A LEISURELY
PACE WITH A FLEET OF POLICE
FOLLOWING HIS TRAIL.
THE MOST FASCINATING PART, THE
SURPRISE ENDING.
[ SIRENS ]
THAT'S YOUR NORMAL CAR CHASE,
BUT THIS ONE MAY BE THE SLOWEST
EVER.
FORT WORTH POLICE FOLLOWED THE
WHITE NISSAN MORE THAN TWO
HOURS.
THE SUSPECT IN NO HURRY TO
ESCAPE, CROWDS OF GAWKERS
GATHERED ON OVERPASSES TO SNAP
PHOTOS OF THE SLOW RIDE, AND AT
ONE POINT THE SUSPECT TOOK OFF
THIS SHIRT, TALKED ON HIS CELL
PHONE.
ONE WITNESS IN TRAFFIC FOR AN
AFFILIATE, GUY WAS WAVING AT US
LIKE HE HAD A PARADE OR
SOMETHING.
POLICE SHUT DOWN HIGHWAYS
ENTRANCES AND CAUSING TRAFFIC
SNARLS.
WHEN YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO
STOP, HE RESUMES HIS SLOW CRAWL
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
I KNOW YOU'RE WONDERING, WHY
DIDN'T POLICE JUST PULL IN FRONT
OF THE CAR?
WELL, IT'S SIMPLE.
ACCORDING TO POLICY THERE,
OFFICERS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO PASS
AND BLOCK A VEHICLE DURING A
CHASE.
INSTEAD, OFFICERS RESORTED TO
LOUD SPEAKERS AND SIRENS.
THEY EVEN PUT OUT SPIKE STICKS.
NO DICE.
HOURS PASSED.
FINALLY THE SUSPECT MADE HIS
MOVE, HIT THE GAS, LEAVING THE
HIGHWAY, WENT DOWN A WRONG WAY
TO GET BACK ON AN ACCESS WAY TO
GET BACK ON THE INTERSTATE.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
A MANEUVER CAUSING THE CAR TO
SLAM INTO A CONCRETE MEDIAN.
S.W.A.T. OFFICERS SWARMED THE
SUSPECT.
WE'RE TOLD A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF METHAMPHETAMINES WAS FOUND IN
THE CAR.
THERE YOU HAVE IT APGUY WHO